to see the difference between cash
accounting and accrual accounting i'm
going to go through this little example
and first i'm going to account for
things using a cash basis of accounting
and then we'll do it with an accrual
basis and just so you have some context
the cash basis is anytime you get cash
from a customer you would count that as
revenue and any time you have to spend
cash you count that as an expense and
you'll see that that's what most small
businesses do while most slightly more
sophisticated businesses would use
accrual based accounting because that
matches up kind of the your your rev
your actual expenses and your revenue a
little bit better in each period so
let's just go through this example using
the cash basis first and we're going to
assume that we start off with no money
so in month one you cater an event where
the cost to you was a hundred dollars
the customer pays you 200 for your
services and maybe they pay your 200
ahead of time so that you have the cash
to go buy
the food and the paper cups and paper
plates or whatever so you get two
hundred dollars in revenue this is a
cash basis of accounting and you have to
spend a hundred dollars of that on
supplies and maybe you have to
hire some help and you have to pay
yourself a salary so if you got 200 and
you used 100 of that your profit here
i'll do profit in green as well your
profit is going to be that's not green
your profit is going to be 100
and if you started with no cash your
cash at the end of period this is going
to be the cash at the end of month one
you will now have 100 dollars of cash
now let's go to month two you cater an
event where the cost to you was 200
the cost was two hundred dollars you and
the customer agree that they can pay you
four hundred dollars the next month so
in this month we have to use two hundred
dollars maybe our bank lets us overdraft
so let's say
we i shouldn't write this is an expense
so i don't have to write negative we're
assuming this is going out i'll write it
in red
so we are going to use 200
but we don't get any revenue because
we're doing the cash basis accounting
the customer is not paying us in that
month they're paying us 400 the next
month so we get no revenue in that
period so it looks like we got no
revenue we had 200 of expenses our
profit here is going to be negative
negative 200 when we look at how much
cash we had a hundred dollars of cash
entering into month two we're using two
hundred dollars of that and so now we've
kind of overdrawn our bank balance maybe
we owe our bank now a hundred dollars
let's go to month two
month two you get four hundred dollars
from the customer in the previous month
you also get two hundred dollars in
advance from a customer that you have to
cater for next month so we've done no
catering this month but we've gotten a
lot of money we got four 400 from the
previous months customer and 200
for a customer that you're going to
cater for next month so we got 600 on
the cash basis in
in revenue and we had no expenses in
that month so we have 600 dollars
in profit and our cash balance increases
by six hundred dollars at the end of
this month we now have five hundred
dollars
now month four you cater the last
customer's event it costs you one
hundred dollars so once again you just
have to spend
i want to do that in magenta
you just have to spend
the hundred dollars in month four to
cater the actual event but you got no
revenue in that month so it looks like
you took a loss negative one hundred
dollars and then your cash balance will
go down to
your cash balance will go down to
four hundred dollars so this is a cash
basis this is how a lot of businesses
run it but as you can see there's a
problem here it looks like our profit is
jumping all over the place
sometimes we're profitable sometimes
we're not sometimes we're profitable
sometimes we're not even though our
business is a little bit steadier than
that would
seem to imply